aber auch luca allerdings freundin ich
sie mal wieder mit der geografie
expertin sandra bullock hey leute heute
wird hier klären die länder sind
italien ein auf ganz afghanistan immer
probleme
da ist das ist avastin auf dürfen
afghanistan tadschikistan
das ist eine mischung aus ostpolen und
japan china gesagt getan
das ist grönland
grönland ja gar nichts mit grüner zu tun
um aber die vergesslichkeit
und da wurde ich wieder angemeckert
martin kleikamp je hatten wir schon mal
brasilien ist doch das grün gelb obwohl
das okay
ich glaube das ist
der hochschulrat oder kolumbien columbia
nicht ich sage ja ich sage das ist
einfach deutschland mit einem in
deutschland mit einem hahn würden oder
so oder belgien
bundesliga fiel das nein nein und mein
gott ich glaube das ist das ist ein job
gibt es gar nicht sage ich habe mich
fürs laufen dass sogar das
ganze hat einfach welt in flagge auf
deutschland umgedreht und
genau aber richtig schön richtig
engagieren
serbien serbien montenegro
[Musik]
columbia salvador
ich würde gerne el salvador als
nachnamen heißen
hendrik
wir nehmen das ist
es was auf jeden fall das ist ein
bundesland
[Musik]
das ist im ausland osten war okay ich
gehe mit salat ich noch dabei sondern
auch heute das was du sagst dass du bei
solchen sachen richtig gut denken kannst
auf einer jeden folge haben würde ich
sagen dann wird mehr
die sowie zwei baden württemberg alles
richtig macht direkt weiter habe ich
natürlich
hier gibt es dann
was geht es dann klickt hier gibt es da
geht es da kirgistan
ich finde dass die autos könnten seien
von
chip.de von sangui ich doch die nazis
das frisch das knistern
lustige sketche gesagt ist in russland
usbekistan in zentralasien zentralasien
denn die allerdings gras oder auf einem
anderen kontinent sind
asien wolltest doch den namen seiner
frau doch ob die anderson mega praktisch
wenn ihr beispielsweise in allen kirchen
seit wir sind der jeden golfer oder in
irgendeinem anderen land außerhalb von
deutschland denn dann könnt ihr einfach
wenn die abends beispielsweise im bett
liegt euren virtuellen standort ändern
und dementsprechend serie oder inhalte
streamen und das ganze mit nur einem
klick mit doch vw könnt ihr vor der
internetfreiheit nutzen und die müssen
sich auch keine gedanken um die
schlechte das internet oder bandbreite
irgendwas machen damit nord links ab
jetzt auch sagen
okay dann da mag es gern so nahm aus
sich nicht nur durch nord links besteht
nämlich keine bandbreiten drosselung auf
zitat aus über 5200 servern in 60
verschiedenen ländern wählen das ist das
geisteskrank ist praktisch nur keine
ahnung irgendwo auf der anderen seite
des planeten bestimmt trotzdem der xbox
ist nicht klar erlaubt oder getan was
kannst du sagen okay ich bin jetzt der
letzte sichere verbindung bin jetzt
eigentlich da und will jetzt einen
komplett legal außerdem feiert jvp
seinem zehnten geburtstag und
dementsprechend könnt ihr etwas gewinnen
dafür bis januar ganz kurz kunden in die
video beschreiben und gucken dort findet
nämlich einen link über einen link
bekommt er einen zweijahresplan plus
einen monat komplett nord vpn kostenlos
und auch nicht das geschenk besteht
entweder hier raus
ist also tief doch die linken in der
infobox und danke an nordkorea dass wir
es heute die heutige video hier
gesponsert haben wirklich und wird live
auf
lettland
das ist
nicht so sagte es werde
das ist mallorca
spanien vergessen
solche tipp geben sollten
das ist bayern
wir haben nämlich dieses mal auch
bundesland fragen wir bei ich will nur
deutschen bundesländer als
20 reichenberg und ein bier und bretzel
ohne bereits sondern sagen ich trete an
praxen oder logo plätzen und sagen den
plätzen die sagen auch nicht verbrechen
sondern es handle ich ja das ist so
optimal portal schon mal geschichte am
bahnhof sagte ulrich warmen semmeln zwar
hat nämlich zu merken
ja nordrhein westfalen
hieß es sowohl auf
litauen jetzt fordert für die tonne du
sagst aber auch nicht ob das jetzt ein
bundesland ist und einem land oder ok
ich sagt sie
ich glaube dass es etwas so jedenfalls
zu weißrussland sagen ich weiß hat dass
die dominikanische republik
kommen jetzt einfach weiter okay
außerdem
will endlich das geheimnis
norwegen
keinen tag einfach nur das
[Musik]
baden württemberg die sache ist nein das
war die schönste flagge die ach je
gesehen habe einfach so ein blasses
blaume zum weißen stern spricht wieder
und seinen da verliert aber dass
dahinter welchen auswandern ich bin nach
mallorca nicht mehr aus sondern
[Musik]
ich sage ganz ehrlich das baden
württemberg das ist somalia
nee das ist das ist nein das ist
südkorea nordkorea das jagd zu sehen
nein nein das ist in korea das ist
nordkorea
[Musik]
du wolltest erstmals
fünfter karibik
deka dws
ist es sarah genau
stimmt das ist ein bundesland safe die
haben auch bei frage haben die flagge
ist immer so sind wie die haben das nie
so
sind nämlich darauf stehen zwar geht die
kamera
ich weiß noch gut gefüllt das als mode
bei flaggen von ländern haben die nie so
viele details die sind immer noch so
simpel zwei farben drei fahren maximal
vier und immer noch so dingsda station
bundesland sachsen anhalt haiti
endlich sagt dem bundesland ja ach so
bremen
sachsen
rückblick das hier nicht letzte flagge
meine damen und herren ist
so seltsam ist dass österreich nebel sei
es so dass ist sie sagen sie das ist
kanada oder das platte damit
das ist wichtig schweiz gescheitert auch
dieses kreuz stimmt am niedrigsten
bundesland saarland ich sag's kolumbien
es ist perfekt oder liebevoll an der
stelle wenn die leute gerade dann auch
beendet wenn es euch gefallen lassen den
daumen hoch oder daumen klickt auf die
noch gewählt weil das nicht verpassen
wollte check die neben der infobox für
vw sei es in der beschreibung nicht
fertig